we're ready to begin our next session
and our first speaker is a fogger he'll
be speaking about the effect of
randomness of ecology
oh good afternoon this is joint work
with my PhD student or inter feed so
I'll be talking about recovering we all
know this problem the input to the
problem is a class and the desired
output is the coloring of the vertices
of the graph basically colors such that
every Edge has two different colors in
its endpoints as we know the coloring is
np-hard
and so we are interesting in considering
a framework that will help us recognize
some easier instances of this np-hard
problem and the framework that I will
describe here can be applied to other
problems as well so what we will
consider is the framework that we call
the hosted coloring framework and in
generating an input within this
framework we have a two choices to make
one is some host graph page and then
within this host of age we plant some
coloring P which is what does it mean to
plant the coloring sphere we partition
the vertices let's say into three groups
and each group is a color class and the
input graph G to the problem is obtained
by removing from H those edges that
violate the legal coloring property the
monochromatic edges so as an example
let's say this was the host of H we
plant in it some arbitrary coloring it's
not necessarily bigand so there are
certain edges which are not legally
colored
we see which I love these monochromatic
edges and we remove them then we'll
remove also the colors from the belt
itself and we give this graph as input
to the algorithm so this is the general
framework and let me challenge is the
following we get G at the input graph
the algorithm never sees the original
graph H or the planted coloring P and
the goal for the algorithm is to legally
free color this graph G in polynomial
time now I should emphasize here that G
may have several legal free colorings
the planted coloring is not necessarily
the unique coloring in this setting so
we were allowed to output any legal free
coloring you don't have to find the
planted one so within this model within
this framework we can have several
different models and here's one which
was studied extensively I saw it I'm not
there yet so like this is really one
that was studied extensively okay so the
house graph is a adversarial and the
planted coloring give a little cereal in
this let's say specific case then
there's nothing you can do it just the
worst case instance so the problem is
np-hard but there are other valuations
of the model so depending on how we
choose h and P the problem can be easy
or difficult so a model that was studied
and described in previous talks here is
the random plate that i colored model so
in this case the host graph one way of
viewing this model it's not always the
way in which this model is described but
that's an equivalent way of describing
it in this you can think of the host
graph is a random G&P graph so each edge
there is present with independently with
probability P and the N vertices and the
planted coloring is random in the sense
that every vertex gets at random one of
three colors and then you remove the
monochromatic edges so this model is
equivalent to what is known as the G and
P K model
okay in this case is three that was
studied before random k colorable graphs
in which there are K color classes and
you just place the edges between the
color classes within a probability P
will use the notation instead of P for
the edge probability we would find it
more convenient to look at to the
notation G and D where D is the average
degree of the graph because it's a bit
more informative to look at it in terms
of the degree and not the property of
the over the edge but it's
interchangeable so our London version
can be not denoted as G and D 3 in our
case in d means that we have a random
graph of average degree roughly T so
there are many walks in this model and
the strongest result known is this
result of alone in Kahala so what they
described is partitioned into two
theorems so the first is that they show
that the spectral algorithm finds the
planted 3-coloring P whenever the
average degree that you start with is
large enough large of any constant times
log n and the second is that even at
smaller values of D and in this case the
planted coloring P is no longer the
uniquely coloring of the graph there
would be other legal free colorings a
polynomial time algorithm can find
illegal free coloring provided that the
initial a degree is loud enough and loud
enough constant so this algorithm starts
with the spectral algorithm but then has
additional steps afterwards so the
spectral algorithm by itself would not
recover the coloring here
and all the results these results of
course hold since it's a random model so
they hold almost surely you for random
choice of GNP so you might be unlucky
and choose a graph on which it fails but
with high probability the algorithm
would work on most cars it will work so
the questions that we ask ourselves is
which aspects of randomness are really
needed for the LAN Kahala results so
that's the host graph leaving it to be
random well can we replace it by some
deterministic maybe choice of graph the
family of graphs let's say graphs with
high expansion would that be enough and
the other question is that the planted
coloring have to be random is it okay if
we let that versary maybe look at the
host graph and partitioning it into
three equal size color classes but you
can choose which builders causing into
which color class does this really make
a difference the out of this talk is
that
I will first review the algorithm of
alone and Karla can sketch how it is
analyzed the very rough sketch then I
describe went what changes when the host
graph is an expander chosen by an
adversary it's no longer entre consider
also what changes when the planted
coloring is also chosen by an adversary
and then pose and some open questions so
to present the results to understand
them better it's good to keep in mind
the following notions of coloring so P
is the planted coloring that we have now
will have a notion of AP approximate
coloring so this is a coloring which is
not necessarily legal but it agrees with
the planted coloring almost our felucca
will only be vertices are colored
differently than the planted coloring so
it's a coloring which is not necessarily
legal but of small Hamming distance from
the tool planted covering a safe be
coloring is something even stronger so
in that coloring you color you don't
color the whole graph you
all vertices except for B Valtor says
all these vertices are colored exactly
as in the planted coloring and the
remaining vertices are just left
uncolored though so you know for sure
that whatever you colored you colored
exactly is in the planted coloring about
the rest you don't know what to do and
the legal coloring is any coloring that
car legally colors the whole graph not
necessarily the planted coloring another
thing that would be helpful in
understanding the algorithms is the
notion of good and bad vertices so let's
suppose we have their house graph is
roughly D regular they can be also a
function of n so think of its square
root n regular is also okay and we have
a planted fully coloring tea so if the
coloring was random then typically every
vertex has one third of its neighbors in
each of the color classes and then the
edges of connecting it to vertices in
its own color class or removed so if
this was the situation we refer to this
vertex as good and if this was not the
situation will FL to the vertex its bed
and it's not how to see that if P is a
random coloring it doesn't matter if the
host cough is random or not but if P is
a random planted coloring then almost
all vertices are going to be good the
faction of good bed vertices is
exponentially small in D in particularly
if it is large of a log and there are no
beta vertices
okay so now we can describe the uncle
algorithm so it has several steps the
first step starts with a spectral
clustering ingles a few words about it
later
in this it after this stage what you
have is an approximate coloring so most
vertices are colored exactly is in the
planted coloring and some small fraction
n over the a1 about diffraction I'll
color differently and this is also not a
legal coloring then oh okay then we have
a local improvement step that are
described as well it reduced it still
gives an approximate coloring but the
reduces the fraction of colors that are
not colored according to the planted
coloring now it's only order of B in
particular if the degree was larger than
log n you finished now at this stage
because B at that case is smaller than
one so you'd get just the planted
coloring but if D is a constant you're
not done the step after that is some
cautions and coloring any vertex that
looks the species for some reason for
example it participates in some
illegally colored edge this is might be
good reason to suspect that something is
wrong with it it's just uncoloured and
the less so in what you get after this
stage if if you do the uncovering
cleverly is that you have a safe or
there will be partial coloring so almost
all the graph is colored and colored
exactly as in the planted coloring and a
few vertices are left uncovered in the
last stage because the number of
vertices which are left and colored is
small you can finish off in coloring
coloring the rest of the vertices using
some dynamic programming algorithm
essentially going all over all
possibilities in some clever way so let
me give a few more details and really
very briefly so the first step is a
spectral coloring so if we consider the
eigenvalues of the adjacency matrix of
the input graph g we look at
most negative eigenvalues and we look at
the egg and vectors that correspond to
them each vertex has an enter in each
eigenvector so this gives an embedding
of all vertices in the plane according
to their entries one coordinated their
entry in one egg in vector or the other
in the other and you cluster according
to distances in this embedding in the
plane and you get a call from these
three color classes which are not
necessarily legal coloring you might
have edges within a color class and the
theorem says that this approach gives
this order and about the approximate
coloring so in a picture what is this
coloring so this is like schematically
the whole graph and the green ridges all
those colored exactly as in the planted
coloring and there are some red regions
where the coloring is different than the
planted coloring doesn't mean that it's
in illegal coloring maybe part of it
which can still be completed to illegal
coloring birthday different than the
planted one the next step is a local
improvement so each vertex can look
locally and see if it's colored if there
is some color class in witches it has
fewer neighbors than its current color
class and if yes it wants to switch to
that other color class because the
coloring would look more illegal this
way so you perform this local
improvement steps and the theorem
showing that sorry after you do this the
fraction of vertices in which you differ
from the planted coloring becomes much
much smaller
so in the picture we started with this
picture and the red regions shrunk by a
lot
the next step is their cautious and
coloring so we suspect that something is
wrong with the belt X if it has fewer
than do bill six neighbors in one of the
other classes so maybe it should have
been in the other classes because
there's only few NATO's in that other
cattle class well not sure about it so
we simply uncover it so now it has no
color it becomes free and the theorem
says is that we don't need to do it for
too many vertices you know and once we
do it the coloring that remains is safe
Africa vertex that still maintains its
color it's because it has exactly the
same color as in the blended coloring
that's the only reason why a vertex
maintained its color and almost all
vertices did it so we start with this
stage with an approximate coloring and
what we do we do some uncovering so some
vertices lost L color and everything
else it's called loda exactly according
to the planted coloring and the last
stage is dynamic programming we have to
show that we can finish off the coloring
now so we have the safe partial coloring
almost everything is colored we have
small regions which are uncoloured and
Aquila are there is that the num it's
not just the number of car vertices that
are not colored can be let's say if
these constant can even be linear in n
so there might be a lot of filters is
not colored but the main theorem here is
that these call vertices which are if I
look at the graph induced on just the
vertices which are not colored it
decomposes into small connected
components each of size not large open
look n enhance on each component I can
do exhaustive search and color it and
it's isolated from the rest of the
component so I can eventually color the
whole graph and complete the coloring so
this is a sketch of the algorithm of a
alone in Kahala so let so the entity is
the following we started with this
of coloring and you completed it to
illegal coloring and this legal coloring
no longer has totally with the planted
coloring so these regions I color them
legally not necessarily exactly the same
as the plaintiff color it so a similar
algorithm the first step of this
spectral clustering that gave an
approximate coloring than some local
improvements which gave a better
approximate coloring then a cautious on
coloring that gave the safe coloring
which is a better notion than
approximate coloring because we make no
errors there and then we finish with
dynamic programming so now we reach like
the topic of this talk so we're like
well did we use randomness in this
algorithm so one question is does the
house of need to be a random graph and
the first step in the algorithm the
spectral clustering uses facts about the
spectrum of the graph about eigenvalues
if we look at the analysis of the other
steps the local improvement step for
example it uses the fact that H the
original graph had high expansion both
these things are captured by requiring
that the host graph sorry that the host
graph being expanded and the way of
measuring the quality of an expansion is
usually by the second largest eigenvalue
of the adjacency matrix so a natural
question to ask is suppose that we allow
that virtually to choose a host of
whatever in any way he wants as long as
the second largest eigenvalue is small
so let's say smaller than the largest
eigenvalue would be D in this case and
the second largest value let's say
smaller than D over 30 and then P the
planted coloring is random
can we still recolor such graphs so
that's the question that we asked
and the algorithm that will run is
basically the same algorithm okay and
the question is good it will start with
a planted spectral coloring local
improvement cautious and coloring and
dynamic programming at the end with the
same thing just to all because it is so
our go team follows the same step it it
turns out that we need to change some of
the details of some of the steps and we
need to change the analysis in some
places and one of the reasons we cannot
use anywhere in the analysis the
randomness of the host curve and another
reason is that the expansion that we
have here is not as good as that of
random graphs so it makes the analysis
more difficult but basically everything
goes through so the one most interesting
may be step that changes in the analysis
is the last day going from the safe
partial coloring completing it using
dynamic programming so that's the one
step waiting well the difference is
maybe more significant if we look at
perhaps the most complicated technical
part of the paper or balloon in Kahala
was to show that in the disturb each
connected component of uncoloured
vertices is small of size order of log n
this was not an easy proof and we still
convent they need to prove such a thing
because in our setting it's even more
difficult to prove it so really what we
showed that even if connected components
of fluid vertices have arbitrary sizes
we can still complete the partial
coloring to a legal one and the reason
why we can do it is because we add one
more step to the algorithm which is
safely coloring it's an obvious thing to
do the point is to show in the analysis
that it really helps so if a vertex V
that we have in the safe coloring has
neighbors in two different colors then
you know what's its own color has to be
it has to be of the third color so just
color these vertices that you know
they'll Karl
what we can show is that the point is
the analysis not the algorithms
algorithms is in a sense obvious that
once you to finish this safely colouring
step then indeed the connective
components are small then you can finish
using dynamic programming and our proof
here uses only randomness of the
plentiful coloring and the whole stuff
does not need to be random it's enough
that it's an expandable so the proof in
fact if it's the expansion is as good as
that of random graphs in the sense that
the second eigenvalue is order of scroll
the the proof is quite easy relatively
easy a counting argument but if the
expansion is not so good then the truth
becomes let's say more interesting
so this part of the work that they
described before more or less showed
that whatever worked for when you have
the whole stuff which is a random graph
essentially all you needed was expansion
and you can modify the algorithm to work
the other question that we asked
ourselves is whether they planted
coloring has to be London as well so the
model is as follows first the house
graph is selected then after sick yes
the cleanup phase the non that's not
happening here right the last but one
step everything uses only spectral
properties rather than randomness is
that so so in a sense what we are saying
so if you look at hundred nests of there
like a house cup is well it is needed so
like it was needed as I said basically
for two properties one is to show that
data that it doesn't have negative
eigenvalues which are too negative and
hence the spectral technique finds
something correlated with the coloring
and then to build upon it we use the
expansion in many of the arguments and
really what this says is that you didn't
need much more that essentially both
these things are captured just by
expansion and you never really needed
the randomness
we didn't look at it yet okay we all
getting epsilon fraction right you can
do this yes so yes so we'll see now what
happens here which is somewhat different
picture so that's the planted coloring
you need to be randoms of the model is
the following there's some host cough
that versa he looks at the host car
rough and chooses three color classes
both of the all of it roughly the same
size and remove the monochromatic edges
and this is the input so we can see the
graph and then do his choices does this
matter
so what changes so one thing that
changes by a lot of this notion of good
and bad vertices that we had before
before we said that the fraction of bed
vertices thought those that don't see
roughly one third of their neighbors in
each color class is exponentially small
indie now it's much larger but it's
still rather small so what we can show
is that the number of bed vertices not
as good as it was before but it's okay
depends on what the second largest
eigenvalue is but it's somewhat smaller
than most vertices are good still good
but a sizable fraction of them are dead
this is something that changes and they
would cause problems for us
so the algorithm we have again the same
general scheme as before now here I'm
looking at the case where the whole
stuff is at first interval Cyril
expander and the flame head colouring is
also adversarial there's no one to miss
at all in this model now everything is
deterministic and adversely chooses
everything subject to one restriction
that the hosts cough is an expander so
the spectral clustering gives an
approximate coloring but the fraction of
badly colored vertices is somewhat
larger than before okay
they were substantially larger the local
improvement gets an improvement the
fraction of a color vertices which are
not colored as in the planted is still
it just be proportional to the number of
bed vertices as it was before but the
number of bed vertices is much larger
than it is it was before the cautious
I'm coloring and gives a safe partial
colonic as before and then we have to
finish off with a little color with
dynamic programming but we need to
kal-el now more vertices that we need
then we had before not exponentially
small indie but something could be
something like one over the function of
the vertices or even a constant function
of the vertices so what's the running
time of the algorithm so the first three
steps of they take polynomial time just
as before and the only question is about
the lasted the dynamic programming does
it take polynomial time or not and we
already colored correctly most of the
graph exactly as the interplanted
coloring almost all the Belcher says so
how difficult can it be to color just
the remaining set of vertices
so here we have a hardness result so we
show that even if the host craft H is
not an orbital expander choses by an
Advil so it's even if it's a random G
and D graph so random graph and the
planted coloring a is balanced so which
color cloud is the same but in adversely
may chose it then the coloring if the
resulting graph is np-hard you cannot
complete this last step in polynomial
time
and our proof require certain conditions
on the host graph so they initially the
our proof applies only to the case well
the host graph has degree and to the
Delta 4 Delta smaller than half and
we've above two feet that's what we know
how to pour about it it may be easy
below it it may be easy but it's n be
held in this region and what's nice
about this result is that it's one of
those other examples in which you can
prove NP hardness for instances which
are mostly random so the house graph was
random so almost all the choices a
random okay that virtually could choose
the planted partition but it's not that
many choices compared to putting on in
all the edges and still you can prove
how this result not under the assumption
that some other random problem is helped
but really until some wall space
assumption
so here's a sketch of the proof so
suppose that there is an algorithm that
pre-colored the graph G generated for
many random G integral of H and in which
energy were three plants on a three
coloring not a random one suppose there
was such an algorithm so what we'd like
to do suppose that Q is some small graph
that we want to three color let's say
and suppose that it comes from some
class of graphs that it's np-hard to
three color then what we'd like to show
that the algorithm would also color this
small graph Q for us because it can
color this model it can also carve a
little bit and the question is why why
would it so that we can pick any Q that
we want and give it to our algorithm it
and it will color it for us so and the
question is why would it do it so the
idea is of course to trick the algorithm
to think that Q is part of some larger
graph that was generated according to
the hosted graph model so the way we do
it we give that algorithm don't ask it
just to color Q but ask you to color
something else Q and so this is a small
graph and next to it a random graph on n
prime vertices so n prime is n minus the
size of Q of average degree D in which
we planted a random free coloring we
give it as input well algorithm and hope
that it would okay this looks to it
exactly what the model should gave this
doesn't but it's small so with it when
it color this it would also color this
for us why would it do it so the
algorithm what we're trying to fully to
think is that really the instance that
he's saying careful
a larger instance that looks something
like the following so this part which is
now tree colorable originally was just a
random G and D graph G n prime D graft
without the 23 coloring Q was sitting
here and it was part of this large graph
it was connected to it by additional
edges and what we wanted to think is
that once we planted a coloring here
so inside Q we planted just the original
three coloring of this car it's not that
we planted it said that everybody knows
everything did it for us a we planted it
in such a way we planted here a coloring
in such a way that all edges going from
here this color class to this side of
the guard all of them we color them
exactly the same color as here and hence
all these cult inches were dropped and
likewise here and here and the reason
why we got this graph here is because we
started from this graph and some edges
dropped and that's why we got this graph
so in a bit more details so we have some
3 colorable graph or we think that we
it's the color level and we want a that
our algorithm to color it for us on n to
the epsilon Delta is a small one
so the adversive sorry
so how would adversely do on input age
from the graph giant from the class G
and D it will find a copy of this small
graph in age plenty in H it's recoloring
AG link with in such a way that edges
between Q and the rest of the graph
would go up and in the simulation what
we give the algorithm is just a disjoint
union of this graphs Markov q and the
random graph and I don't have much time
but the main thing so Q cannot be to
spouse because otherwise it not would
not be np-hard and it would cannot be
too dense because otherwise this would
not work it would not be contained in H
and the main lemma that we prove that
the graph obtained by these two
different processes one is one a what
that really does and one is what we do
in the simulation that these two things
are statistically indistinguishable not
computationally indistinguishable time
in the stronger notion they really look
the same so this is not a non trivial
proof this is the main source of the
hardness Society so let me just
summarize so where these will there was
a known prior to our work so when we
have a random host graph and
contemplated coloring the algorithm of a
loan in Kahala could find the coloring
and we ask what happens if there's an
adversarial plan blended coloring in
adversarial autograph which is an
expander so if we just look at finding
approximate coloring then spectral
techniques of 5 in all these cases if we
look at safe partial colorings which is
a stronger notion a still everything
works and the interesting things begin
once we want to complete it to a legal
coloring
so this I did not show if their host
office adversarial and that the planted
coloring is adversarial its np-hard for
article is essentially and the
interesting thing happens when the
random graph they host off is random and
they tended coloring is adversarial here
when the degrees are larger than I
didn't show it here n to the 2/3 you can
find the coloring when they were between
n to the point for an end to they have
it's NP held and in these regions we
don't know so I'll finish with our open
questions so out of polynomial time free
coloring algorithms for the following
settings so one is the following let's
say that the host glove is the random
G&T graph with D roughly n to the 1/4
below where we could prove NP hardness
and the plentifully coloring is
adversarial so this is one open question
that we don't know how to pool our
techniques for proving and P hardness
completely break down because at this
density at higher densities we could
show that the host graph contains a sub
graph curves which are how to color any
specific graph that I want if it's small
enough if a sub graph of such a house
curve once the density is so low like n
to the one quartile then it's no longer
2 so we don't know and the other
question which i think is even more
interesting if the following suppose the
host graph is arbitrarily and well so
you can choose it any way it wants and
they planted color after coloring is
random so for example the host of by
itself could be 3 colorable that's okay
but then you plant in it random free
coloring so you partition the vertices
into three random classes and they move
edges within each class can we color
such graphs so as a reminder what we can
do is if H is a not orbital but an
expander we can do it if H is arbitrary
but of large enough to carry think of
the gray
that's a lineal degree or maybe another
log and we can also do it but in general
it seems unlikely that we can do it but
we don't know how to prove that it's out
you get some Springs volatile
Mississippi if I had a just wage that
only increases the expansion yes I think
it's a practice that helps in the
coloring but the expansion goes it down
right is that right am i right
and so you mean are you the filling -
are you the feeling back to this earlier
here that is a bit strange now I want to
do semi-random
I mean oh you okay severe and so we
didn't get to semi random here I mean
this model is an adversary big in as it
is so let's say what we did now maybe
for convenience if I'm not sure we have
to think how these things extend we
talked about graphs which are either
regular or nearly regular which makes
the spectral analysis let's say simply
written have to look at the Jason C
matrix you don't have to look at things
like maybe the laplacian matrix or some
other matrix which is works better when
graphs are not regular so what you are
talking about introduces these
irregularities also so we didn't get
there
then it doesn't matter that they don't
not you though technically if you look
at this this is somewhat interesting
that the results here that if you start
from a graph which is relatively usually
you would think that the spouses the
host stuff is the more difficult it is
to color but this we don't know how to
prove it so it could be that in this
region it's easy to color you at random
edges and it becomes difficult to color
it just between colored glasses even
vandeman I just might help help you we
don't know this model per se 3sat so you
have maybe some interaction yeah so you
can think of other problems within this
model so let's say for this a random
3-cnf formula would be something like
our model would say start with an
arbitrary
3-cnf formula maybe you want to enforce
some expansion conditions or something
on it and then in the diversity for
example or at random you pick a
satisfying assignment in throw away all
the clauses which are not satisfied by
it so yeah so this model can be applied
to many problems I mean you're using
constant expansion for the amount of
expansion so the point here was in a
sense so they okay so one thing if you
just want to do this thing most close to
handle graphs we take the second
eigenvalue to be one of to be square
routine much smaller so one of the
points of this work was to show that you
really don't need such good expansion
it's still very good expansion what
we're taking but not as good as you have
in random graphs much worse than random
but and then the question is what
happens as the expansion degrades there
I'm sure that there's some play-doh fee
involved but we didn't work it out
curious I mean if you write this result
as a risk his result yes how do you
think or you know how unlikely is it to
actually get such a graph if you look at
you know distributions that have been
studied before are they all very weird
or do they just tend to be hard in this
regime where we show the NP hardness so
the NP hub is the thing that we use is
that the adversary chooses the planted
coloring I'm not sure that people looked
so much at this version
well that virtually makes this choice so
you know like what we the point was to
show I think that okay that if you give
him this choice it doesn't need anything
else that's enough to make the problem
difficult even if it's a random dog that
Belser has to solve NP hard problems to
generate these instances